new details in takeoff's fatal shooting
five shots fired downstairs in the wake
of the rapper's death early Tuesday
morning
the Harris County coroner's office
confirms to E.T takeoff died as a result
of gunshot wounds to his head and torso
we want to make sure that Justice is
found for the people involved
police say the 28 year old was killed
outside of this Houston bowling alley at
approximately 2 30 this morning our
officers were dispatched out here to a
shooting upon arrival they located
multiple shell casings take off and
Migos band meet cuevo who also happens
to be his uncle were reportedly playing
dice when an altercation broke out and
someone opened fire you are affecting
culture across pop music everywhere who
doesn't understand who needs to know if
you're part of the culture and a part of
hip-hop and music you need to know for
takeoff music was a family business
[Music]
he was the youngest member of Migos
alongside quavo and his cousin Offset
you know you get to share
life-changing moments with people who
you change your life for and it's like
what better way else to do it or with
your family how we believe in each other
and only us you know what I'm saying
there's been no arrest so far in the
investigation they do have surveillance
video cameras here in the uh the complex
our investigators have reviewed the
cameras and are still in the process of
reviewing them
foreign